[Musik]
>> SALLY: Hallo!
Herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Welt!
Wir haben gerade richtig Lust auf Burger.
Unsere Burger Buns, also die Brötchen
haben wir schon gemacht.
Da könnt ihr euch mein Grundrezept anschauen.
Denn ich habe einmal
ein Grundrezept für ganz klassische Burger Buns
und dann noch ein Grundrezept gemacht
für diese hohen, fluffigen, megaluftigen Burger Buns.
Die sind nämlich in so einem Burgerring gebacken.
Da könnt ihr danach schauen.
Die haben wir bereits vorbereitet
und werden jetzt
eine richtig leckere Teriyaki-Soße dazu machen.
Die bereiten wir als Erstes zu.
Die kann man auch super vorbereiten
und auch wirklich im Kühlschrank lagern.
Da passiert nichts.
Dann habt ihr immer was auf Vorrat.
Danach werden wir noch die Patties selber herstellen
und den Sommerburger richtig lecker belegen.
>> ELA: Mama?
>> SALLY: Wir gucken mal, ob wir heute alles fertig kriegen
>> ELA: Mama, was stinkt hier?
>> SALLY: oder morgen noch einen Teil.
Was hier stinkt?
Das ist der Essig, Ela.
Ach, ich liebe deine Ehrlichkeit!
Also für die Teriyaki-Soße...
Für...
Und du mit deiner verstopften Nase, du riechst das, ja?
>> ELA: Ja.
>> SALLY: Ja?
Dann muss es ja richtig stinken.
>> SAMIRA: Ja.
>> SALLY: Okay.
Für die Teriyaki-Soße verwenden wir
200 Gramm Sojasoße,
100 Gramm braunen Zucker,
20 Gramm Stärke,
drei Knoblauchzehen,
30 Gramm Ingwer,
einen Esslöffel Sesamöl
und 40 Gramm Reisessig.
Guck mal, Samira.
Wir geben jetzt schon mal den braunen Zucker hier rein.
Und du darfst den karamellisieren.
>> SAMIRA: Oh!
>> SALLY: Ich glaube, du weißt, wie das geht.
>> SAMIRA: Ja.
>> SALLY: Das heißt, auf den Herd
und dann mittelhohe Hitze,
nicht rühren, sondern einfach nur
langsam schmelzen und karamellisieren lassen.
Genau.
Unser Herd geht bis 9.
Samira hat jetzt auf 5 gestellt.
5 oder 6, das passt.
Ich kann in der Zwischenzeit schon mal
die Knoblauchzehen und den Ingwer hacken.
[Musik]
>> ELA: Mama, guck mal Papas dicken Bauch an!
>> SALLY: Oh!
Hast du da etwa gerade Menschen gemalt
und der einzige, der einen Bauch hat, ist der Papa?
>> ELA: Ja,
ein dicker Bauch.
>> SAMIRA: Ela, nee!
>> ELA: Doch! Der hat...
>> SALLY: Der Papa...
>> ELA: Das stimmt halt!
Der isst immer Süßigkeiten!
[Musik]
>> SALLY: Hm.
Und jetzt einfach lassen, nicht rühren.
>> ELA: Es riecht einfach nach Chili.
Mama, es riecht scharf!
>> SALLY: Echt?
>> ELA: Ja.
>> SALLY: Guck mal, Ela.
Du kannst auch mal kurz was machen.
Und zwar
>> ELA: Das riecht ja gut.
>> SALLY: darfst du hier
die Stärke einrühren.
Also ich nehme jetzt hier die Sojasoße.
Jetzt Stärke in die Sojasoße.
Da kannst du jetzt noch den Essig dazu geben,
>> SAMIRA: Mama?
>> SALLY: der so ein bisschen stinkt.
Da nehmt ihr Reisessig oder Apfelessig zum Beispiel.
Reisessig wäre natürlich
japanisch.
>> SAMIRA: Mama, es karamellisiert.
>> SALLY: Und jetzt verrühren, ja?
Ich gebe es dir mal hier rüber.
>> SAMIRA: Mama, es karamellisiert.
>> SALLY: Es karamellisiert?
Nicht rühren! Nicht rühren!
[Musik]
Den Ingwer und die Knoblauchzehen einfach auch hier mit rein.
>> ELA: Ich finde die super.
[Musik]
So. Das sieht jetzt hier super aus.
Perfekt geschmolzen.
Jetzt geh mal ein bisschen zur Seite.
Weil jetzt kann es passieren, dass vielleicht was spritzt.
Und Karamell ist sehr, sehr heiß!
Also da wirklich aufpassen!
Am besten auch jetzt kurz den Herd runterstellen.
Und wirklich sehr vorsichtig arbeiten!
Und los! Damit ablöschen.
Und es ist völlig normal,
wenn jetzt ein dicker Karamellklotz entsteht so wie hier.
Denn der Zucker wird jetzt durch die kalte Soße
natürlich erst mal fest.
Aber der schmilzt gleich.
Und jetzt müssen wir die Soße einfach nur noch...
>> SAMIRA: Kann ich das machen?
>> SALLY: Moment. Warte,
bis die gefährliche Situation vorbei ist.
Jetzt gerne wieder den Herd ein bisschen hochschalten,
dass es wirklich auch schön aufkocht.
Mit Pfeffer abschmecken.
Und dann die Soße aufkochen lassen und etwa vier Minuten
dann wieder bei mittlerer Hitze köcheln lassen.
Und abschmecken,
also mal gucken, Salz, Pfeffer, ob alles passt.
Und natürlich ist es eine Teriyaki-Soße.
Da muss ja der Zucker rein,
weil man eben diese Sojasoße ausgleicht.
Und es ist wirklich eine Soße,
die sich perfekt haltbar machen lässt
eben durch den Zucker.
Und dann haben wir gleich eine leckere Burgersoße.
>> ELA: Mama?
>> SALLY: Oder auch eine Soße für was anderes.
Also das ist so ein Grundrezept.
>> ELA: Ich habe noch einen Menschen gemalt.
>> SALLY: Hast du gemalt?
>> ELA: Da ist er.
>> SALLY: Cool!
Mit Kopfhörern!
Ist das der Josh?
>> ELA: Nein, das ist der...
Das sage ich dir jetzt nicht.
>> SALLY: Cool! Guckt mal!
Mit Kopfhörern!
[Musik]
Ich glaube, wir müssen tatsächlich,
damit die Soße nicht zu dick wird,
ein bisschen Wasser zufügen.
>> SAMIRA: Mama?
>> SALLY: So 50 Milliliter.
[Musik]
Jetzt ist die Soße perfekt!
Ich habe sie noch ein bisschen verfeinert
mit Wasser und Zucker.
Ich schreibe euch einfach die genaue Menge
in die App.
Dann wisst ihr da Bescheid.
Und jetzt werde ich sie hier reingießen.
Ich werde allerdings, glaube ich,
für die Flasche
das Ganze sieben,
damit ich praktisch die Stückchen nicht drin habe.
Ihr könnt sie auch pürieren,
aber muss nicht.
Wow, es sieht so schwarz aus!
Mega!
[Musik]
Es sieht super aus!
Und dann mache ich noch ein
– das ist so die Kinderversion.
Weil die Kinder,
ich glaube, wenn ich die jetzt frage,
"Wollt ihr mit Stückchen oder ohne?",
eher ohne.
Und für uns lasse ich aber die Stückchen drin.
So.
Also da gebe ich die einfach wieder zurück,
weil ich Knoblauch sehr mag und Ingwer.
So.
Die gebe ich jetzt hier rein
und kann jetzt beide Gläser verschließen,
die Soße aufbewahren.
Und die ist jetzt wirklich auch mehrere Wochen haltbar.
Denn ich habe ja Zucker als Konservierungsmittel
und habe die Soße eingekocht.
Jetzt stelle ich die kurz weg
und kann schon mal das Fleisch vorbereiten.
Da habe ich jetzt ein Rindfleisch bereits gekauft
in großer Menge,
werde kurz Hackfleisch daraus zubereiten
und dann eben die Patties formen.
[Musik]
Hier habe ich mein Rindfleisch.
Wie gesagt, ich habe ein bisschen mehr.
Denn ich friere auch immer gerne was ein.
Wichtig ist im Prinzip nur,
dass ihr es lang schneidet,
nicht in Würfel, damit der Fleischwolf
einfach das Fleisch auch schön greifen kann,
um die Spirale wickelt und fertig.
Da muss man auch fast nicht nachstopfen.
[Musik]
Das Hackfleisch wird jetzt noch kurz durchgeknetet,
damit sich einfach das Fett mit dem Fleisch verbindet.
Das reicht schon.
Hui!
Und ich mache das Ganze jetzt hier mit einer Burgerpresse.
Es geht für mich einfacher.
Ihr könnt aber auch einfach eine Portion nehmen,
zu Kugeln formen und flach drücken.
Aber, wenn ihr Patties macht
und sie wirklich gleichmäßig geformt sind,
dann sind sie natürlich auch gleichmäßig gar.
Also ich habe ja, wie gesagt, eine Burgerpresse,
die ich endlich auch mal zum Burgermachen benutze.
Ansonsten immer nur so für Torten.
Und ich mache jetzt, glaube ich, Kingsize.
180 Gramm.
Ja.
Das heißt, ein bisschen Backtrennspray drauf.
Das Elakind ist da mit einem Besen.
Ach Gott!
186 Gramm
ist auch okay.
Haben wir wieder das Augenmaß?
Haben wir es wieder da?
Und jetzt drücken.
Nach dem Festdrücken mit einer Palette zum Beispiel
oder einem stumpfen Messer am Rand entlangfahren.
Dann löst es sich von ganz alleine.
Und ich gebe es jetzt hier auf so ein Alublech,
was wirklich auch schön ins Gefrierfach passt,
mit einer Backfolie.
Da ist auch extra diese Wölbung drin,
eben auch, damit das Fleisch später beim Grillen
eben sich nicht so zusammenzieht und schön durchgart.
So.
Das mache ich jetzt
und friere sie dann ein.
Denn gerade das Einfrieren ist wirklich ein super Tipp,
damit die Patties später eben auch nicht auf dem Grill kleben.
Das heißt für mich,
ich habe jetzt die Soße vorbereitet,
ich habe meine Burgerbrötchen vorbereitet
und den Rest
mache ich dann aber erst morgen.
Denn die können jetzt
einfach über Nacht in den Gefrierschrank.
Aber eine Stunde oder zwei reichen auch.
Und dann machen wir morgen nämlich
unsere Summer Burger fertig.
[Musik]
Ich habe eine Kugel geformt.
Dann verteile ich das hier so.
Und dann drücke ich es fest.
Schön platt drücken.
Und ihr könnt so einen dünnen Burger machen
mit 120 Gramm
oder Kingsize 180 Gramm.
Aber das sieht perfekt aus!
[Musik]
Diese große Menge hat natürlich den Vorteil,
ich mache jetzt einfach alle fertig
und wenn sie dann gefroren sind,
kann ich sie nämlich verpacken
und habe einfach für die nächsten Grill-Burger-Events
schon mal meine Patties fertig.
Und wenn ihr dann noch Brötchen eingefroren habt,
ist das Burgergrillen wirklich ein Kinderspiel!
Also, wenn ihr Platz im Gefrierfach habt.
[Musik]
Und jetzt so einfrieren.
Und wenn sie gefroren sind,
werde ich sie einfach in eine Schüssel verpacken
und kann sie dann übereinander stapeln
und dann können wir sie morgen grillen.
Heute ist der nächste Tag.
Heute gibt es Burger.
Und ich habe jetzt hier schon alles vorbereitet.
Schaut mal, die Patties habe ich wirklich gut eingefroren.
Jetzt habe ich sie einfach luftdicht verpackt.
Die habe ich im Gefrierschrank.
Falls wir einfach
die nächsten Wochen wieder Burger haben möchten,
habe ich sie schon bereit.
Hier habe ich meine Brötchen.
Und da möchte ich noch kurz dazu sagen:
Hier habe ich ja jetzt diese hohen Brötchen mit 150 Gramm,
hier die flacheren mit 100 Gramm.
Also es war wirklich so:
150 Gramm, da bekommt ihr
aus dem Grundrezept 12 Stück raus.
Wenn ihr 100 Gramm macht, sind es etwa 18 Stück.
Und ich finde, gerade für Samira und Ela
sind die flacheren etwas besser,
vor allem zum Essen.
Und für Murat, für uns, für die Erwachsenen
waren schon die hohen ganz gut.
Nur, dass ihr das zur Info wisst.
Ich werde jetzt hier dazu noch Salat servieren,
habe noch rote Zwiebeln
und eine Ananas.
Denn ich habe mir gedacht so:
"Sommerburger? Was passt da dazu?"
Irgendwie Ananas, Teriyaki-Soße.
Ich glaube, das wird ganz gut.
Wir probieren es später einfach.
Und ich habe noch nie
eine Ananas auf einem Burger gegessen,
aber in meiner Vorstellung ist es ganz gut.
Ja. Was mache ich zuerst?
Ich bin eigentlich gleich fertig, gell?
Ich erhitze jetzt schon mal meine Pfanne.
Denn draußen regnet es.
Wir gehen leider nicht auf den Grill.
Wir stinken die Küche zu.
Jetzt kann ich hier meine Grillplatte kurz einfetten.
Da nehme ich jetzt die mit den Streifen,
weil ich einfach supergern diese Streifen habe.
So.
Und ich kann jetzt schon mal das Brot
auch halbieren, dass es bereit ist.
[Musik]
Guckt mal, wie locker und leicht
und superfluffig die geworden sind!
[Musik]
Die Ananas schält ihr entweder mit einem Messer
oder mit einem Ananasschäler und -schneider.
Finde ich einfacher,
weil ich so direkt zwei Arbeitsschritte in einem habe.
Und man kann hier auch ablesen,
wie viele Scheiben es sind.
Und wenn ihr nicht bis ganz nach unten dreht,
könnt ihr es rausnehmen
und habt sogar noch einen Cocktailbecher!
Also Ela und Samira,
denen fülle ich dann einfach Wasser ein
und dann nehmen sie Strohhalme
und schlürfen hier ihr Ananaswasser raus.
Es ist schon ganz cool für die Kids.
Ich glaube, ich bewahre das denen auf für später.
Ja.
Ich fange jetzt hier auch schon mal an,
nebenher die
Fleisch-Patties zu grillen.
Denn wir sind ja wirklich gleich fertig.
Und erst wenden, wenn sozusagen
die erste Seite gut gegrillt ist.
Hier löse ich das da hinten jetzt ab,
kann es hier rausnehmen.
Und ich will ja jetzt Scheiben haben.
Also schneide ich einfach hier, wo dieses Ende ist,
einmal von oben nach unten durch
und habe jetzt praktisch meine Ananasscheiben.
[Musik]
Was man übrigens auch wunderbar machen kann:
Ich nehme jetzt mal noch eine Ananas,
schneide hier oben den Deckel weg
und schäle und schneide sie in einem Zug.
[Musik]
Dann entferne ich hier oben den Griff.
Hier habe ich jetzt noch ein Gefäß direkt mit dabei
und setze jetzt hier
diese Scheibe auf.
Ich kann nämlich direkt die Ananasstückchen
dann praktisch hier reingeben.
Ihr könnt sie da drauffallen lassen,
die Ananasspirale,
und direkt die Stückchen schneiden.
Hier der Deckel mit dem Stiel.
Und dann einfach nur noch sanft drücken.
Perfekt!
Und dann habt ihr einfach eure Ananasstückchen
– die drücke ich hier noch kurz durch –
und habt sie direkt,
wenn ihr hier den Stiel entfernt,
in der praktischen Aufbewahrungsdose
und könnt eure Ananasstückchen einfach aufbewahren.
Das mache ich vor allem ganz oft,
wenn die Ananas so kurz vor dem Abgang ist.
Also ich merke so,
"Oh, ich habe schon wieder zu viel Ananas gekauft
und ich benutze sie gerade nicht",
dann mache ich das so.
Ich kann sie entweder einfrieren
oder Ela, die ist total gerne Ananas,
und habe sie einfach schön verstaut im Kühlschrank.
Und sie ist wirklich einsatzbereit.
Die Zwiebeln.
Ich habe jetzt hier rote Zwiebeln.
Da schneide ich jetzt mal dicke Scheiben runter.
Ihr könnt aber auch dünne schneiden.
[Musik]
So. Die sind jetzt perfekt!
Ich lagere die jetzt einfach nur ganz kurz hier
so zum Warmhalten sozusagen.
Jetzt grille ich noch die Ananasscheiben.
Ich mache halt jetzt erst mal drei Burger fertig.
Ich kann das Brot schon mal erhitzen
und gleich belegen.
Was ich zur Teriyaki-Soße noch sagen muss,
ich musste noch mal heißes Wasser reinfüllen,
denn die wurde über Nacht
durch das Abkühlen echt richtig fest.
Aber, wie gesagt, schreibe ich euch da
die genaue Menge einfach rein.
Denn
ich habe nicht damit gerechnet,
dass sie so fest wird,
so richtig so geleeartig schon.
So.
Hier habe ich noch Salat.
Und dann geht es gleich los.
Josh, du darfst dann gleich probieren.
>> JOSH: Ich bin schon gespannt!
>> SALLY: Ich auch.
Denn Ananas auf dem Burger hatte ich noch nie.
Aber Ananas auf der Pizza liebe ich.
Du?
>> JOSH: Früher hatte ich auch
immer Pizza Hawaii gegessen.
>> SALLY: Echt? Okay.
>> JOSH: Ich bin so ein bisschen davon abgekommen.
Aber eigentlich mag ich es auch.
>> SALLY: Eigentlich ganz gut, nicht?
>> JOSH: Ja, eigentlich ist es ganz gut.
>> SALLY: Okay.
Weil da gibt es, glaube ich, so Menschen, die es lieben,
und Menschen, die sagen: "Nee."
>> JOSH: Ja.
Ich glaube, da
>> SALLY: Ich glaube, ich nehme jetzt doch...
>> JOSH: scheiden sich auch die Geister,
ob man das darf oder nicht darf.
>> SALLY: Ich glaube auch.
Ich nehme das Fleisch jetzt doch schon mal raus,
damit das Brot Platz findet.
Aber so Burger grillen ist schon,
wenn man es gut vorbereitet,
schon eigentlich ganz chillig.
Man kann jetzt auch die große Platte nehmen.
Da passen natürlich viel mehr drauf.
Aber ich wollte jetzt so für uns hier
drei, für uns drei hier
nicht so viel machen.
[Musik]
Josh, die Zwiebeln anbraten oder nicht?
>> JOSH: Mh.
Also ich bin eigentlich immer Fan von geschmorten Zwiebeln.
>> SALLY: Ich auch.
Ach, so ein paar?
>> JOSH: Du kannst sie ja kurz anschwitzen.
>> SALLY: Ja, die schwitze ich hier noch kurz mit.
Okay.
Ich würde sagen,
ich packe jetzt hier Teriyaki-Soße drauf,
lasse den Lkw vorbeifahren
und dann etwas Salat.
Und ich bin Fan von noch mal Soße.
Denn das Fleisch ist ja, wie ihr wisst, nicht gewürzt.
Das heißt, das Fleisch schmeckt einfach nur nach Rindfleisch.
Und dann das Fleisch.
Ich würde jetzt noch ein bisschen Pfeffer darüber geben,
einfach für den Geschmack.
Salz lasse ich mal weg,
denn die Teriyaki-Soße ist ja wirklich schön würzig.
Dann die Zwiebelchen.
Die könnt ihr gern noch länger schmoren
oder eben so lassen.
Ich hätte jetzt noch eine zweite Pfanne
praktisch hinstellen müssen,
die flache Pfanne für die Brötchen
und für die Zwiebelchen.
Aber ich wollte jetzt einfach ein bisschen sparsam sein.
Und noch mal final etwas
Teriyaki.
Und
heute die Premiere:
Ananas.
Habe ich was vergessen?
Nein.
Das warme Brötchen.
Et voilà!
Und, weil man so einen Burger
so eigentlich auch nicht wirklich
servieren, präsentieren kann,
kommt noch ein Burgerspieß rein.
Wenn ihr normale Burger macht,
nehmt ihr diese Burgerspieße.
Wenn ihr de luxe Burger macht,
nehmt ihr diese.
Ich glaube, heute nehmen wir diese, oder?
Soll ich?
Zack!
Und dann fällt er auch nicht auseinander,
bis er am Tisch landet.
Also das ist unser Burger.
Josh, ich würde sagen,
wir zwei probieren. Okay?
Und ich finde, das ist auch so ein Burger
wie bei Hans im Glück.
Also entweder isst man ihn aus der Hand
und es ist einfach furchtbar egal, wie man danach aussieht,
oder ihr esst ihn mit Messer und Gabel.
Egal.
Wie ihr möchtet.
[Musik]
Burger, Burger!
>> JOSH: Ich bin...
>> SALLY: Hier, Partner.
>> JOSH: Ich bin sehr gespannt.
>> SALLY: Ich auch.
Vor allem so Soße, Süße, Fleisch, Salat, Brötchen.
>> JOSH: Ja. Also das ist so eine Kombination,
>> SALLY: Tschüss, Mama!
>> JOSH: – Tschüss! –
die hat man auch im Burgerrestaurant echt noch...
>> SALLY: Noch nie, nicht?
>> JOSH: Also habe ich noch nie probiert so was,
muss ich echt sagen.
>> SALLY: Also, lieber Hans im Glück,
wenn du noch glücklicher werden willst,
probier mal meinen Burger aus.
Aber ich möchte auch, dass er dann Sally heißt.
Also ich mache jetzt so.
Wie hättest du den jetzt gegessen? So aus der Hand?
>> JOSH: Ja, schon.
>> SALLY: Also ich habe ihn auch gestern Abend gemacht
und habe ihn aus der Hand gegessen.
Aber wir können jetzt nicht zusammen reinbeißen.
>> JOSH: Ja.
Das wäre ein bisschen komisch.
Vor allem muss ich sagen,
ich hatte gerade schon Angst davor,
als du gesagt hast, ich soll probieren,
dass ich mich jetzt so dumm anstellen muss,
um so einen Burger, der höher wie breit ist,
irgendwie davon abbeißen muss.
>> SALLY: Tja.
>> JOSH: Also dann machen wir das mit Messer und Gabel.
>> SALLY: Also have fun!
Also ich als Dame hätte jetzt sowieso
– den Deckel würde ich runternehmen,
essen und dann einfach noch mal belegen.
>> JOSH: Ich muss sagen, das verstehe ich nicht
bei einem Burger,
>> SALLY: Ja, aber wenn er halt so hoch ist.
>> JOSH: die Leute, die den Deckel runternehmen.
Und dann?
>> SALLY: Und dann einfach noch mal belegen.
>> JOSH: Aber dann ist es ja ein belegtes Brot,
wenn der Deckel fehlt.
>> SALLY: Ja, das stimmt.
Aber wenn er halt so hoch ist
und ich ihn nicht essen kann, dann ja.
>> JOSH: So ein bisschen hier Ananas
und von dem Brot hier.
>> SALLY: Mmh!
>> JOSH: Mmh!
>> SALLY: Ich bin Fan von Ananas auf Burger.
>> JOSH: Gerade
>> SALLY: Gell?
>> JOSH: die Süße.
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> JOSH: Super ausgewählt!
>> SALLY: Und dann die Teriyaki-Soße.
>> JOSH: Megagut dazu!
Mmh!
>> SALLY: Mmh!
>> JOSH: Das ist so ein perfekter Burger
für so einen Sommerabend,
so einen Freitagabend.
>> SALLY: Ja. Ja. Boah!
>> JOSH: Wir haben jetzt halt heute Regenwetter.
>> SALLY: Leider.
Aber ich habe ja noch Vorrat.
>> JOSH: Okay.
>> SALLY: Wir heben uns die Soße auf,
die Brötchen auf und das Fleisch auf.
Ich packe noch ein bisschen Soße drauf.
>> JOSH: Oh, megagut!
Oh, krass!
>> SALLY: Lecker!
>> JOSH: Also ich muss sagen,
der kommt unter die Top 3 der besten Burger,
die ich je gegessen habe.
>> SALLY: Wuh!
>> JOSH: Definitiv.
>> SALLY: Ah, du hast
meinen Grana-Padano-Burger verpasst.
>> JOSH: Ja. Nee, den kenne ich nicht.
>> SALLY: Der...
Dieser,
dieser
oder dieser.
Ich weiß nicht, wo ihr ihn verlinkt.
Grana-Padano-Burger.
Das war so von Alex.
>> JOSH: Krass!
>> SALLY: Der ist heim und hat gesagt:
"Iris,
ich kann nichts mehr essen.
Ich habe den besten Burger der Welt gegessen!"
Das war der Grana Padano.
>> JOSH: Ich muss noch mal ein bisschen.
>> SALLY: Der gehört definitiv auch dazu.
>> JOSH: Also auf jeden Fall Top 3.
>> SALLY: Und der Chili Cheese.
Und der Birkenwald.
Jetzt könnt ihr hier, Jungs, alles schön verlinken,
alle Burger.
>> JOSH: Ist noch Platz im Bild für uns irgendwo?
>> SALLY: Ist noch Platz im Bild für uns?
Vielleicht hier in der Mitte.
Also viel Spaß beim Nachmachen!
Probiert es unbedingt aus!
>> JOSH: Mmh!
>> SALLY: Ich liebe den Burger mit Ananas!
Und ich bin so froh,
dass ich heute nur ganz wenig gefrühstückt habe.
Denn jetzt gibt es Burger für alle!
>> JOSH: Viel Soße!
>> SALLY: Und viel Soße!
>> JOSH: Megagut!
>> SALLY: Die Soße ist echt...
>> JOSH: Oh, Achtung! Er stürzt ein.
>> SALLY: Woah!
Ja, wir haben jetzt schon...
Aber ich glaube, ich muss ihn einmal auch ins Bild drehen,
wie er jetzt aussieht, hey!
>> JOSH: Wow!
>> SALLY: Guckt euch das mal an!
Also der ist wirklich grandios!
Also tschüss!
>> JOSH: Megagut!
>> SALLY: Bis zum nächsten Mal!
>> JOSH: Tschüss!
>> SALLY: Yummy!
>> JOSH: Kann ich den fertig essen?
>> SALLY: Ja, nimm das ganze Brett.
>> JOSH: Komm. Ja.
Da passt dann nämlich noch ein zweiter und ein dritter drauf.
Das ist ganz gut.
>> SALLY: Ja. Komm. Genau.
>> JOSH: Ich komme gleich zurück für Nachschlag, okay?
>> SALLY: Okay, okay.
>> JOSH: Der Dreh ist unterbrochen für zehn Minuten
und dann.
>> SALLY: Okay.
>> JOSH: Tschüss!
>> SALLY: Es gibt leider keine Videos mehr.
Tschüss!
[Musik]